un été marqué par des chaleurs records
33 jours de canicule les jeux d'eau
comme à l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et les
piscines sont prisées au zoo de Thoiry
les soigneurs distribuent des sorbets et
smoothie aux animaux pour les rafraîchir
le député de la deuxième circonscription
Jean-Noël Barraud nommé ministre délégué
au numérique il laisse son siège à
l'Assemblée nationale à sa suppléante
anne-grignon suite à un recours elle ne
reste députée que quelques jours déjà
suppléante au Sénat les lune ne peut
cumuler les deux fonctions et
démissionne de nouvelles élections
partielles auront lieu en octobre une
mise en service très attendue celle du
tram T13 cette ligne relie en 30 minutes
Saint-Cyr l'école à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye en août le Sport
reprend ses droits le FC Versailles
découvre le championnat de National par
une victoire au stade Jean Bouin
l'équipe s'impose de Buzin contre
Martigues une belle lancée le
département haute des championnats du
monde de golf amateur votre équipe s'est
au Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et à
Saint-Nom-la-Bretèche 56 délégations
pour le tournoi d'âme 72 pour les
messieurs le golf à l'honneur de nouveau
fin septembre avec le retour de l'Open
de France à Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
après 2 ans d'absence 156 joueurs
présents
du domaine d'Ores à château fort et
sélectionné pour le loto du patrimoine
2022 le monument du 19e siècle va
bénéficier d'une restauration à hauteur
de 129000 euros une rentrée en pleine
inflation aux Mureaux l’épicerie sociale
ils avant à nouveau des fournitures
scolaires à des prix réduits pour les
familles en difficulté au collège le
département des Yvelines des poissons
cartes à bleu numérique pour 130 000
jeunes et professeurs du territoire des
premiers jours de cours particuliers
pour les élèves de la British School of
Paris à Croissy-sur-Seine deux minutes
de silence observées en hommage à la
reine Elizabeth décédé à l'âge de 96 ans
le zoo de Thoiry a un nouveau
pensionnaire l'éléphanteau d'Afrique
Moyo neuf ans rejoint l'autre pachyderme
du parc ben âgé de 42 ans c'est le
festival de l'entreprise en France le
victoire de BPI France fait état au
Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines découverte de métiers
recrutement création d'entreprises et
innovations au programme de la journée
et puis plus de 25000 coureurs prennent
le départ du mythique Paris Versailles
la course revient enfin après la
pandémie de covid-19 une 43e édition
remportée par Anaïs Kenner chez les
femmes côté homme une grande première
avec un versaillé vainqueur Justin
bourlant